[موسيقى]
اقول الحكايه ان فرعون لم يكن ذكيا وكان
يعتمد على دهائها مان ذات يوم وقع فرعون
في مشكله حيث قصدتهم امراه عجوز من قوم
امه تطلب من عطوفته ان يتكرم باحياء
عنزتها الميته ذلك ان فرعون قال لهم انا
ربكم الاعلى وانا احيي واميت في لحظه
الحيره يتدخل هامان ويعطي المراه عنزه
عوضا عن عنزتها التي نفقت مشي حالك فيها
لان فرعون مشغول جدا الان بخلق الابل قال
لها ففرحت العجوز بالهديه وانصرفت
في المساء سال فرعونها مان عن العجوز فقال
له اطمئن لقد خرجت من عندنا مسروره بعد ان
اعطيتها عنزه جديده واخبرتها بانك مشغول
بخلق الابل
تنهد فرعون وقال اه يا هامان لو تعلم كم
اتعبني خلق الابل فرد هامان بقوله الشهير
على هامان يا فرعون الى العناوين
متى ستثلج فرنسا عن خرائط الغامها الارضيه
في الجزائر
حواس يريد تكميم الماذن في القاهره ومصريه
تنجح في اطلاقها في فيرجينيا
اوروبا تكتشف ان الصين متورطه في قمع
المراه الايرانيه فمتى ستكتشف من يقمع
الفلسطينيين
هل يتعارضوا الحجاب مع اللبننه ومن الذي
يحدد الثقافه اللبنانيه
[موسيقى]
مرحبا واهلا بكم الى حلقه خاصه تجمع من كل
واد عصى ونبدا بالابر ماتروبي هو مرض يصيب
العيون فيفقد صاحبه القدره على التركيز
على الاشياء القريبه منه بينما لا يجد
مشكله في النظر للبعيد بعض المنظمات
الدوليه ربما تكون مصابه بالابر ماتروبين
ببعد النظر فتستطيع من لندن مثلا رؤيه
دقائق الامور في افغانستان البعيده ولا
تبدو الصوره واضحه لديها في باريس القريبه
ربما بسبب القنابل الدخانيه التي داب عسكر
فرنسا على ترويع المتظاهرين السلميين بها
افغانستان تتراجعوا في مجال حقوق الانسان
تلك هي خلاصه تقرير جديد لمنظمه العفو
الدوليه للوضع تحت حكم طالبان يعترض
الفرنسي دائما في المحافل الدوليه على نشر
روسيا الاسلحه في جوارها وهو اي ماكرون لم
يفرج واسلافه بعد عن خرائط الالغام التي
نشرتها جمهوريتهم في الجزائر ابان
احتلالها الدموي وما تزال اشلاء الاطفال
الجزائريين تتطاير حتى اليوم على مذبح قيم
الجمهوريه الفرنسيه اكثر من
7300 ضحيه حصيله مؤقته لالغام فرنسا
الاستعماريه التي زرعتها على طول الحدود
الشرقيه والغربيه للجزائر الجزائر تمكنت
حتى الان من تطهير اكثر من خمسين الف
هكتار ملغمه لكنها لم تستطع التخلص نهائيا
من الخطر نتيجه مماطله السلطات الفرنسيه
في تسليم خرائط توزيع الالغام اخر ضحيه
لهذه المخلفات طفل في مقتبل العمر لقي
حتفه نتيجه تعرضه للغم في منطقه سوق اهراس
الحدوديه شهر مارس المنقذي تقول اليونيسف
ان ملايين الاطفال في اليمن يواجهون مخاطر
متزايده بخصوص سوء التغذيه دراسات اخرى
تقول ان معدلات سمنه الاطفال تتزايد في
اماكن اخرى من العالم والجوع كما السمنه
يهددان الطفل بالموت فاذا كنت ميسورا داوي
طفلك باطعام طفل جائع من فائض طعامه طفل
يموت كل عشر دقائق في اليمن هذا ما خلصت
اليه منظمه الامم المتحده للطفوله
اليونيسف محذره من ان ملايين الاطفال
يواجهون مخاطر متزايده بخصوص سوء التغذيه
في هذا البلد اذا لم تخصص اموال بشكل عاجل
له ليس التكاليف الحياه فقط صعبه بل
تكاليف الموت ايضا في بعض الاحيان فقد
ارتفعت مؤخرا اسعار المقابر في القاهره
وبعضها تضاعف في الاحياء المصنفه بالراقيه
وضمن المقبره الواحده تختلف الاسعار بحسب
اطلاله القبر لفيو والتشطيبات الحرفيه له
بعد حياه طويله او قصيره لا مفر للانسان
من هذا المصير المحتوم لكن لم يعد كثيرون
في مصر قادرون على توفير مقبره يوارون بين
ثراها اجسادهم او اجساد احبابهم بعد تضاعف
اسعارها خلال الاونه الاخيره الاسعار
تتراوح في خلال من 150 احل لحد مثلا مليون
جنيه على حسب الاماكن وعلى حسب المناطق
اللي فيها المدفن وعلى حسب التشطيب اوضاع
لم تمنع مجلس الشيوخ المصريه من الموافقه
على مقترح بانشاء مقابر فاخره للعظماء
الشيخ العراقي بشير النجفي يجلس في غرفته
فيرى كل ما فيها صناعه اجنبيه حتى
النظارات والالبسه التي يرتديها مستورده
لا شيء صنع في العراق يحدث ذلك منذ النهضه
الكبرى التي فجرتها امريكا في العراق
نظرت
اضاعه مستورده
حتى هذا مستورد
كانوا سكان عشوائيات في مدينه الغزاليه
العراقيه
ولاجبارهم على الرحيل عن مساكنهم صاروا
تجاره مخدرات ودعاره واعضاء بشريه في
اتهام جهات نافذه غير حكوميه قررت اجلائهم
عن المكان طبعا لم يتهموهم بداعش ربما
بالنظر الى لون المنطقه تجار المخدرات
اغتصاب الزنا المحارم يعني متهمين اتهامات
باطله على مود يطلعونه بهذا الاشياء في
اقصى مدينه الغزاليه منطقه عشوائيه يعيش
اهلها تحت الضغط والتهديد اكثر من الف
منزل على هامش التجريف مهددين من قبل جهات
متنفذه لما نقدر نذكرها لانه للاسف الدوله
ضعيفه هسه انا اخاف من الناس المتنفذين بس
من الدوله ما اخاف
كانوا في الجاهليه يعلون هبل والان يعلون
الهبل يقال ابراهيم عيسى الذي يريد
استبدال السنه النبويه الشريفه بتقديس
البقر يدافع عن الفن الهابط جدا
الهجوم عليهم دام يعني خطا وغريبه
محمد رمضان ويجز دوله
نماذج نجاح عظيمه للفن المصري كلهم في
مجاله ولما تشوف نسب المشاهده الجنونيه
على اليوتيوب
بالمليارات تقريبا ولما تشوف هذا الانجاز
الرائع
لنجوميتهم وسط يعني النجوم العرب لازم
تعتز جدا وتفخر باللي عامله محمد رمضان
واللي عامله ويجزه احنا لابد ان احنا يعني
نفرح بهم ونعتز بيهم وندعمهم ونساندهم
ونقيدهم طب مايا خليفه حطمت ارقاما قياسيه
في المشاهدات ايضا بحسب الصحافه الامريكيه
فهل على لبنان ان يقيم لها تمثالا بنص
ساحه الشهداء ببيروت مسيو يا عيسى
[موسيقى]
بعد ترويجة لاكل لحوم الحمير مذيع الثروه
الحيوانيه في مصر يطلق حمله جديده للبدء
بالتهام الحشرات قل الحمير وتحلى
بالصراصير انت بتدافع يعني ايه
مش حقيقي خالص طب شغلها كده تاني نشوف
الاحساس كان ايه ليه ما بناخدش لحمه حمير
انا من وجهه نظري لماذا لا ياكل المصريون
الحشرات بس لما
دي بتاعتك انت لا هنبداها مستعد انت بقى
كان تامر قبل صحوته الحميريه وفق تعبير
خليل خليل صاحبه لبههيش كان يعتبر من
يذبحوا الحمار لاكله حماره فذبح الحمار
وبقي مذيعنا المكار
[موسيقى]
طب بالنسبه لاصحاب الحمير
تم ضبط والتحفظ على الحمار فين بقى الحمار
اللي ذبح الحمار ولا دول الاخوه لهم مش
عارف الخبر ما قالش الحقيقه بس واضح ان
احنا عندنا
اننا مشاكل في موضوع الذبح واللحوم وبتاع
ومحتاجين رقابه اكتر يعني من ست سبع سنين
كان اللي ذبح الحمار
ومحتاجين رقبه اكتر انما دلوقتي ليه ما
ناكلش لحم الحمير عشان
دول علشان اصبح واقع لحم حمار لا طبعا
[موسيقى]
حكايه الاذان ده اللي هو الاذان يعني ما
يتعمل جوه المسجد ليه الاذان وسبعين اذان
يعني صوت الاذان بيقوح السواحل قاعدين
احنا دوله سياحيه فلازم برضو نحافظ على
راحه السايح طبعا ده شكوى بيشتكي منها
السواح في مكان كتير جدا ومش موجود في اي
بلد في الدنيا غير عندنا تذكرونا خبير
المصريات كما يطلق على نفسه زاهي حواس
تذكرون كيف اعترض مؤخرا على اطلاق الاذان
عبر مكبرات الصوت في ماذين القاهره مدعيا
ان ذلك يزعج السياح وقال ان هذا الاذان
بمكبرات الصوت غير موجود في العالم الا في
مصر وهو كما تعلمون موجود في كل العالم
الاسلامي بل اصبح من الممكن سماعه في
الغرب وحتى في امريكا
تمكنت رنا عبد الحميد وهي شابه مصريه يعني
مواطنه زاهي حواس تمكنت من الاستحصال على
تصريح رسمي لرفع الاذان للصلوات الخمس
ولاول مره عبر مكبرات الصوت في مسجد
بمدينه نيويورك
[موسيقى]
لاول مره في تاريخ نيويورك يسمع المسلمون
صوت الاذان عبر المكبرات حيث نجحت الفتاه
رنا عبد الحميد في الحصول على تصريح رسمي
يسمح برفع الاذان عبر مكبرات الصوت في
ثلاثه مساجد اذ سيصبح الاذان بصوت واضح
ومسموع كانه يرفع في بلد عربي او مسلم في
الولايات المتحده ايضا وتحديدا في ولايه
فيرجينيا رفع الاذان مؤخرا في مسجد افتتح
حديثا بعد ان كان كنيسه تاريخيه
لا اله الا الله
[موسيقى]
كثيرون قد يستغربون الان كيف تتحول كنيسه
تاريخيه في الولايات المتحده
بموافقه من مرجعيتها الدينيه ومن الدوله
الى مسجد الجواب والاسباب يكشفها قصيص
كنيسه اخرى كاثوليكيه عريقه في ولايه
نيويورك تحولت الى مسجد عيسى بن مريم
عليهما السلام تقع هذه الكنيسه في مدينه
سيريس بولايه نيويورك
ويعود بناءها الى مئه عام ماضيه عام 2013
كان افراد من الجاليه الاسلاميه في
المدينه يبحثون عن مكان يبنون فيه مسجدا
لهم فصادفوا مبنى الكنيسه الذي كان يبدو
عليه القدم والحاجه للترميم
[موسيقى]
بدات اتصالات الجاليه الاسلاميه بالقائمين
على الكنيسه بهدف تحويله الى مركز اسلامي
لكن الامر لم يخلو من تعقيدات وحساسيات
صار القرار بين يدي القسيس جان المسؤول عن
مجلس اداره الكنيسه وكان عليها ان يختار
فوافق على بيع المبنى للجاليه الاسلاميه
لتحويلها الى مسجد
خوف من تحولها الى مول او ملهى الليليه
كما حدث مع كنائس اخرى في اوروبا وامريكا
[موسيقى]
تلاحظون ان ما يسمى بالديانه الابراهيميه
قد خفت صوتها بعد موجه الرفض العلماء
العريضه في العالم الاسلامي والتي قادها
الازهر الشريف لكن من طرح الفكره للجهد
وسيكرر المحاوله باستمرار عبر ادواته
وامكانياته بحسب الشيخ الازهري محمد يسري
ابراهيم الخطوره والاشكال تكمن في امور
الامر الاول في استعمال بعض المؤسسات
الدينيه والرموز الدينيه للترويج لهذا
المشروع ولو بغفله من رؤوسها هذه مشكله
اولى المشكله الثانيه ان هؤلاء القوم
يغلفون المساله بغلاف التنميه وغلاف
الرشاوه الاقتصاديه فيزينون هذا الباطل
بانه سوف يفتح ويغدق علينا شيئا من السعه
رفض كوكتيل الاديان هذا المسمى بالديانه
الابراهيميه وصل الى اوساط الفنانين فقد
قال محمد صبحي انها خطه جهنميه منحطه
افتعلت فقط من اجل خدمه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي والقوى الاستعماريه رايك ايه
في الديانه الابراهيميه شايفها يعني شايف
اللي بيحصل ده ازاي ان احنا نبقى قال
الدين اليهودي والمسيحي والاسلامي كلنا
اولاد سيدنا
ما ينفعش نسال السؤال ده ليه لان ده
خطه جهنميه وسافله ومنحطه انت بتسلبيني
ديني ازاي عايزه تنسعي كل هذه الموروثات
علشان حفنا من البشر المجرمين يحكموا
العالم هذا في صالح الكيان الصهيوني رولا
مكي امريكيه من اصل لبناني وهي اول مسلمه
ومحجبه تنتخب لمنصب قيادي في الحزب
الجمهوري الذي يوصف بانه لا ينتهج سياسات
صديقه للعرب وللمهاجرين عموما بينما تقول
رولا ان الجمهوريين يعارضون فقط الهجره
غير الشرعيه لكن بهيج يسال هل علينا ان
نفرح بوصول الحجاب الى مراكز القرار ام
بوصول العدل اليها
اكتشفت التقارير الاوروبيه مؤخرا ان الصين
متورطه فيما وصفته بقمع المراه الايرانيه
حيث ان كاميراتي مراقبه تطبيق قانون
ارتداء الحجاب في شوارع ايران قد صنعت في
الصين فاستبشر العرب خيرا بان تتمكن
التقارير الاوروبيه والغربيه عموما من ان
تكتشف لاحقا ان الاسلحه والذخائر التي
يقتل بها الفلسطينيون قد صنعت في الغرب او
بتمويل من الغرب وفي اضعف الاحتمال برضا
كامل من الغرب من خلال استخدام
التكنولوجيا والمعدات الذكيه سيتم التعرف
على النساء غير المحجبات ليتم بعد ذلك
اختارهن برسائل نصيه ثم تقديمهن الى نظام
المحكمه مع المستندات اللازمه لمعالجه
القضيه
مسلسل النار بالنار خلف اسئله حول مدى
احترام بعض الدراما اللبنانيه للمراه
المسلمه المحجبه المسلسل الذي ينتجه ابن
الجنوب اللبناني صادق الصباح يعني الموضوع
مش طائفي اعتبر حين عرض على الشاشات انه
يسيء لحجاب المراه المسلمه في مشهد تخلع
فيه امراه سوريه الحجاب لكي توحي بانها
لبنانيه فتحصل على جواز سفر لبناني مزور
عفوا
تطلع صوره احسن هيك
يعني اي حدا رح يمسك الباسبور رح يعرف انك
مش لبنانيه
[موسيقى]
يرجح البعض ان اكثر من نصف اللبنانيات
محجبات بين مسلمات ودرزيات وراهبات مسيحيه
فما حدا يحاول يسود وجهه وسجل له مع كل
هول ويلي مش عاجبه الحجاب بلبنان في
عروضات دائما على تذاكر السفر لعند ماكرون
تعلق محجبتان لبنانيتان
مهضومتان هيدا يا جماعه الخير الباسورد
تبعي مثل ما شايفين كلياتكم محجبه بين مثل
ما شايفين لبناني الواقع بقول لكم انه
نظرا لانه في كثير مسلمين بلبنان فاكيد في
كثير محجبات في لبنان وهذا الامر الطبيعي
يلي انتو اردتم انه تغيروه ما بعرف ليه
قرات تزورونا باماكن طبيعيه وساعتها
بتشوفوا قديش حتلاقوا محجبات بكافيه بسيطه
بمطعم بسيط بشوارع الحمراء او وين ما درته
باي شارع بلبنان راح بتلاقوا فيلم محجبات
مش ضروري تشرح الحجاب لحتى لتبيني لبنانيه
ولا ضروره تتعرى لحتى لتبيني لبنانيه انما
هيدا الفن يلي انتم قررتوا توصلوا للعالم
بكل الاحوال بعض الدراما العربيه لا
يعيشوا واقعا اقل سوءا وانحطاطا من واقعنا
العربي العام تخيلوا لاخذ فكره عما نتكلم
ان قبند عاشت الاسامي هو زعيم المنتجين في
بلاد الشام وهو منتج احد اكثر المسلسلات
العربيه استمرارا وانتشارا باب الحاره
وسيروي قصه حياته المفخره بفيلم امريكي
يقول انت قلت قصه حياتك راح تنكتب وراح
تتمثلوني شلون ولدت
الكذب عم بيكتبه
معقوله عم بقول اكتبها بعدين بتجي النسخه
الثانيه برج
بطل ادرس الارض السوريه تطلع واحد ممثل
ثاني بس مش فاهم يعني هذا العمل يمكن
امريكي
[موسيقى]
تحيه لاعلامنا انا ممثل الشعب انا بيني
وبينك
[موسيقى]
في المتفرقات بملابس الاحرام شاب اندونيسي
يعقد قرانه على فتاه امام الكعبه المشرفه
ويثير الجدل حول صحه فعله لم نعرض الموضوع
على اهل الاختصاص الذين بدورهم قد تختلفوا
ارائهم لكن بكل الاحوال نتمنى التوفيق
للعروسين والذريه الصالحه في ربوع
اندونيسيا كبرى الديموغرافيات المسلمه في
العالم في نكاوى كنيسه يعتقد افراد رعيتها
ان شفيعها سان لازارو قادر على شفاء
الكلاب والحيوانات الاليفه من الامراض وفق
تقرير نشرته وكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه
حيث يتوافد المئات من المصلين الى الكنيسه
في مدينه مسايا وقد البسوا حيواناتهم
ثيابا ملونه طلبا للتبرك نيسان لازارو
كثير من الضباط ومن رتب عاليه جدا حول
العالم يلقبون بالارانب عندما يدق النفير
لكنهم يرفعون منسوب التوتر عند شعوبهم
دائما وحده الارنب بيرسي يحفز محيطه على
الفرح والحيويه والنشاط هذا ما يقوله
العاملون في مركز للشرطه في كاليفورنيا
يستعين بالارنب بيرسي فيمنحه رتبه ضابط
العافيه
ويكلفه بمهمه مساعده زملائه في الشرطه على
التخفيف من الضغط النفسي والتوتر اثناء
الدوام الرسمي اخيرا واجه طائر كركه
تمساحا مغيرا في مدينه ساراثوتال
الامريكيه
ونظر كل منهما الى الاخر في مواجهه نادره
وفي النهايه نجح الطائر الضعيف الذي عاده
ما يكون الفريسه باخافه التمساح القوي
فالنصر يحالف احيانا قوه عزيمتنا واصرارنا
على الحياه والبقاء حتى لو كنا مستضعفين
[موسيقى]
ختاما يقول الكاتب الامريكي ارنست هامينج
ان الموت والحمقى هم فقط الذين لا يغيرون
ارائهم ابدا لذلك لا بد من حين واخر من ان
نعيد النظر في بعض مواقفنا التي لا تندرج
ضمن الثوابت والمسلمات
شخصيا وبعد طول تفكير وجدت ان الحكام
العرب عادلون في احكامهم صادقون في كلامهم
حازمون في قراراتهم ويقفون على مسافه
واحده من الجميع انهم حكامنا العرب
الاجلاء في لعبه كره القدم فهل تقدرهم
الفيفا كما ينبغي التقدير الى اللقاء
بيسالوني
جرى
[موسيقى]
الغير طبعا
وبيقولوا لنا
والرحمه
راحت مننا
[موسيقى]
جم وسالنا
اناشيدنا وغلبنا
عايشين على
اعصبنا
عمري الهم مسابنا
لامي تعيشنا في بوقي السبع
وانتو تقولوا
نصيبنا
دنيا ودايسه علينا
من الغلب بتسقينا
ولا حد شال ملكه في مره
ولا
طبطبته علينا
[موسيقى]